les rapports sont claires il ya un
nouvel ennemi une nouvelle ressource
illimitée de jeu pour y est apparue et
on ne sait pas qui est derrière tout ça
effectivement presque rire tu as raison
et au on est là
mais [ __ ] mais je vois que dan avec
ses lunettes il fait tout noir là en
plus on peut pas enfin bref le disait
que les choses ne vont pas être aisée ce
coup ci regarde
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
celle ci s'est moins en main j'aime bien
parce que j'ai une casquette dessus
j'adore on peut revenir au sujet
regardez plutôt les preuves sont formels
et ma chienne se dirige vers sion ne
sont en train de creuser des machines
entièrement dédiés à un seul but notre
destruction nous n'avons que quand huit
cantons vous le savez je trouve que ça
sonne bien calé les ultimatums on va
jamais y arriver on est foutu calme-toi
ou une rare et des compresses un peu
c'est facile à dire je bosse depuis 15
mois et vous m'avez jamais payé il
faudra mais l'élu à la source pour qu il
reprogramme le code original afin de
reformater le système tout comme ça quoi
quoi très bien pas de temps à perdre
mais avant tout chez une question je
t'écoute voiture et cie qui tous ces
gens là
bonjour 1e armée n'ont eu en fait c'est
les membres du club qui occupe la salle
habituellement
un second groupe désigné arrive
extraction d'urgence quand tout le monde
retourne à ce tissu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde ont déjà abordé
plusieurs fois cette console mais je me
suis rendu compte qu'on n'a jamais pris
vraiment la peine de la présenter je
vais donc réparer cette injustice en
vous présentant le gamecube parce que
oui on dit le gamecube c'est un garçon
regardez sorti en 2002 soit deux ans
environ après la sortie de la
playstation 2 le gamecube était
annonciateur du renouveau de nintendo et
c'était la première console de la firme
japonaise a enfin abandonné le support
cartouche pour le céder malheureusement
face à l'écrasante playstation 2 il
était difficile de rivaliser et la
console de nintendo comme pour la
nintendo 64 ne pouvait compter que sur
ses licences phares zelda wind waker
mario sunshine ou super smash bros pour
ne citer que ces trois là alors la
console ne fut pas non plus un échec
commercial mais elle arriva à peine à
concurrencer la xbox arrivant en
troisième position des ventes pour
l'histoire d'ailleurs après le gamecube
beaucoup de gens voyaient arriver la fin
de nintendo sega venait de signer son
arrêt de mort en tant que constructeur
de console avec la dreamcast et nintendo
avec la nintendo 64 puis la gamecube
avec même enchaîné deux semi échec on
voyait déjà xbox et sony devenir les
seuls constructeurs du marché mais
finalement l'expérience tirée de ce
semi-échec permettra quelques années
plus tard à nintendo de revenir avec le
carton planétaire que sera la wii
est une fille
l'a 13 ans cette année
du coup de cette blague est dégueulasse
alors on a déjà abordé quelques jeux de
cette console quoi man batman dark
tomorrow catwoman charlie's angels mais
il ya un jeu que je vois régulièrement
revenir dans la liste des pires jeux les
plus horribles de toute la sixième
génération de consoles c'est bad boys 2
sorti en 2004 alors de ce qui me semble
l'histoire du jeu semble plus ou moins
être un truc parallèle a les traits du
film enfin je crois je suis pas allé
vérifier en fait parce que je ne sais
pas je me fais déjà qui a joué à cette
merde je vais pas en plus à les revoir
bad boys 2 une seconde fois fallait
connaît on commence donc le jeu alors
qu'une jeune demoiselle s'arrête dans un
liner pour commander à manger pour son
collègue mais alors qu'elle passe la
commande soudainement une bombe explose
tuant son coéquipier
dans y'a personne dans la voiture ne dit
rien profil de la qualité du travail de
l'acting
[Applaudissements]
bref le jeu donc visiblement à l'air
d'un tps tout à fait classique mais
chose de spécial ou alors attention
accrochez-vous parce que c'est le seul
truc original du jeu dans ce jeu il
existe un système de moralité ou tu peux
devenir un flic exemplaires pour un bad
boy non plus tu as pas des gens plus tu
deviens un bad boy on peut quand même
admirer la tentative de m système de
moralité dans un jeu où tu passes ton
temps à buter des gens sans leur
demander de se rendre avant al'inverse
pour devenir un flic exemplaire il faut
désarmer les ennemis en tirant sur leurs
armes sauf que ces genres juste beaucoup
trop chiante faire sa peine je veux dire
il faut viser précisément le pixel de
leurs armes à longue distance et à peine
c est quand à jean cecchet demi en face
suis censé faire comment on est sur
console je rappelle un stage ou avec une
manette bonjour la galère pour viser
[Musique]
mais [ __ ] arrêté oui je vais même pas
parler genre de la stupidité du jeu qui
te permettent dé foi de désarmer les
ennemis avec un fusil à pompe
le libero m pour être un flic exemplaire
pour désarmer l'anomie toujours viser
larmes
voilà l'ennemi est désormais à la fin de
chaque niveau votre chef fera le bilan
de vos tirs de vos cibles a battu de là
où vous avez brisé et créera par exemple
on voit que l'ag a battus 47 personnes
et désarmé huit autres ça va pour cette
fois mal et puis le jeu il est gentil
quand même par exemple là on voit que
j'ai seulement cinq exécutions c'est à
dire à 5 personnes qui se sont rendues
qui se sont mis à genoux mais que j'ai
quand même abattu d'une balle à la tête
et mon chéri le canton et regarder
personnes exécutées
c'est pas si mal
notez d'ailleurs que votre compteur de
bad boy augmentera aussi quand vous
faites des dégâts matériels et
d'ailleurs ça augmentera même vachement
plus du coup but est un mec ça va mais
alors cassé une planche quoi alors bref
d'ailleurs je reviens vite fait à
l'histoire du jeu mais pourquoi dans le
niveau est ce qu'on se balade dans les
salles d'arcade du quartier ont du temps
tout le monde au fait non parce que à la
base on devait se courir la fliquette
mais ça on le fait dans les trois
premières minutes de la mission et après
je sais pas pourquoi mais le jeu
continue et on se balade dans la cité en
tuant les gens ce genre on s'est dit bon
bain et on connait là j'en avais assez 1
j'avais cette bande de racailles
évidemment l'intelligence artificielle
de ce jeu c'est la gastro classique les
ennemis court partout au pif comme des
adolescentes déguisé en licorne à la
japan expo il reste planté devant vous
comme des vieux plots attendre de se
faire muter et quand par miracle lie à
du jeu réussi à trouver un couvert
[Musique]
et évidemment on n'oublie pas la petite
cerise avec la caméra qui paniquent
déconner dans le bruit de couloir à bâle
c'est pas mal là le plan de caméra c'est
pas mal pour viser les ennemis dans la
salle j'aime bien on peut essayer
d'avoir mieux peut-être est-ce qu'on
peut
bien bien et d'ailleurs je vais aussi
parler du système de couverture de ce
jeu parce que ça aussi faut en parler en
fait le jeu ne t'accorde que certains
endroits pour te cacher qui sont
indiqués par ces ronds au sol et du coup
on est en permanence dans des situations
qui sont complètement ridicules je dire
gens regardez ici là le couvert veut que
je me mette là mais si je me mets ici et
que je me relève pour tirer je suis
derrière la caisse et du coup je vois
pas les ennemis [ __ ] alors je veux pas
vraiment juger ce jeu à la va vite mais
pour moi ce jeu c'est un petit peu comme
la merde collé au fond des chiottes
c'est à dire que bon ben c'est là ça
sent plus vraiment mauvais depuis le
temps que c'est là mais c'est pas non
plus le truc que tu as envie de montrer
à ses invités et en même temps tu as un
petit peu envie de pisser dessus
je juge ne peut quand même là alors on a
pas mal avancé dans le jeu et les
niveaux dégagent tous autant de fun
qu'une soirée photocopieuse c'est tout
le temps la même chose les niveaux sont
interminables parce que vu
l'intelligence des ennemis la seule
façon qu'ils ont trouvé de maître de la
difficulté dans ce jeu c'est d'avoir des
vagues d'handicapés mentaux qui viennent
s'empaler sur toi sachant que l'autre
difficulté c'est les niveaux et de
protéger ton équipier de sa propre
stupidité non billy ne te cache pas
derrière le canon ça ne pète pas non
billy se mettre à couvert ne signifie
pas rester au milieu d'une plaine place
d'ailleurs au bout de dix minutes de ce
jeu mais tu vendrait ton âme pour qu'ils
ferment leur gueule déjà bad boys le
film les dialogues ça volait pas haut
mais là vos deux personnages passent les
niveaux entiers à s'envoyer toutes les
quatre secondes des [ __ ] de vieilles
punchline rouyer qui ferait passer des
spectacles de anne roumanoff pour du
molière et je me suis fait trop et le
cul par des russes ça c'est vraiment
pompon mais pourtant n'a pas de pompe au
[Applaudissements]
rêve je ne sais pas c'est réellement ce
jeu mérite sa place dans le top 5 des
pires jeux existants m'est avis que les
gens qui ont fait ces classements jamais
jouer à dragon serre mais en tout cas il
mérite bien sa place dans la poubelle
ou la gaufre ou est ce qu'on est
c'est pas vrai nous l'avons offre répond
moi et j'en sais rien moi c'est bloqué
sur un écran de veille à la con monnier
nous devons aller voir le rock seule
elle pourra te permettre de venger la
mort de ton chien et empêcher le bus
d'exploser s'il dépasse la barre des 50
miles more heures vous avez raison de
toute façon
cette intrigue n'a aucun sens cependant
éloigné il ya quelque chose que tu dois
savoir propos de l'irak
je peux te montrer la porte et du il
n'appartient qu'à toi de la franchir
enfin vous dit quelque chose ça fait
trente minutes que vous aviez pas parler
et pourquoi vous pouvez pas venir
d'ailleurs en fait possède une
injonction d'éloignement
on a eu un petit différend
bienvenue et lui elle vous attend
est plutôt beau garçon
qui êtes vous et un peu idiot oui mais
on va se calmer je te dirais bien de
phase aller mais tu préfère rester
debout et toute façon je n'ai qu'une
seule chaîne of war et d'ailleurs ne
t'inquiète pas pour se battre
quelle base
je suis vraiment désolé je t'ai dit que
ce n'était pas grave tu viens chercher
mes conseils tu cherches ton rôle à
jouer dans toute cette histoire et tu te
demandent sûrement quelle est la suite
cette vidéo
et ne t'en fais pas pour cet accord
ailleurs que l'accord l'yonne
ouais merde tu es vraiment désolé oui
c'est pas grave mais attention s'il te
plaît
la vérité est que pour avancer et pour
trouver le jeu suivant tu devrai d'abord
de trouver toi-même
regarde
est ce que ça veut dire c'est pas venu
pour 3 euros à la farfouille il ne
t'inquiète pas pour cette horloge j'ai
emmené ou est ce que tu veux ça
c'est incroyable vous voyez vraiment le
futur hélas combien je dois cacher
derrière mon dos écoute on va abréger
prend ce jeu et par la réponse est là
dedans d'accord et c'est grâce à ça que
je vais pouvoir trouver la source du
code de la matrice
c'était deux doigts ouais c'est ça
dégage mais alors du coup il faut
toujours que je me trouve moi même non
c'est bon on s'en fout casse toi merci
oracle je savais qu'on pouvait compter
sur vous
la saga matrix une des séries les plus
cultes des années 2000 quasiment chaque
scène de ce film était culte la scène du
bullet time a été parodié des milliards
de fois ce film en tout cas le premier
c'est pour moi le film qui marque un
petit peu la césure entre les films
d'action des années 90 et leur ton un
petit peu léger et les trucs un petit
peu plus dark des années post 2001 2003
sort le second opus matrix reloaded
suivi de quelques mois plus tard à peine
toujours en 2003 du troisième matrix
revolutions les films ont évidemment eu
droit à plein de mini bonus notamment
les animatrix des films d'animation que
je vous recommande vivement et deux
jours avant la sortie du deuxième film
on a même eu droit à un jeu vidéo qui
devait se dérouler en parallèle de
l'intrigué du deuxième film et faire
plus ou moins la liaison avec le
troisième c'est enter the matrix qui est
accroché vous le jeu vidéo tiré de films
qui s'est le mieux vendu de l'histoire
ce sera donc forcément excellents
le jeu va donc suivre les aventures de
niobé et ghost deux personnages qu'on
retrouve dans le deuxième film alors par
contre soyons clairs si tu n'as pas vu
les films matrix le jeu tu abandonnes
immédiatement au bord de la route comme
un chien au mois de juillet donc je vais
considérer que vous avez tous vu les
films et si vous les avez pas pu aller
les voir on a donc affaire un tps assez
classique ou vocale
ok alors juste avant de commencer à vous
parler du jeu juste un petit mot sur
l'animation de course je sais un que
dans matrix tous les personnages courent
comme ça mais ça marche parce que dans
le film ils sont poursuivis mais là
enter the matrix c'est 70% du temps des
couloirs vides sans aucune menace et oui
je sais on va dire non et angie devient
la mauvaise foi ils rament pour rien
mais oui mais c'est aussi conquis dans
un rpg ton personnage il allait acheter
du pain comme ça et encore je parle que
des animations courts suis gentil je
parle pas du reste
donc niveau contrôle dans ce jeu on
possède deux boutons pour le corps à
corps une chope pour désarmer les gens
un bouton pour tirer un pour sauter et
évidemment vous avez une barre de
concentration qui vous permet d'activer
le fameux bullet time ralentit le temps
et vous donne la possibilité d'effectuer
toutes les actions matrix yens au combat
combat qui alterne d'ailleurs entre le
vrai matrix bien sympa à regarder avec
des mouvements bien chorégraphiés mais
qui assez souvent tourner à la baston du
tambour et avec des personnages qui
reçoivent qui bloquent des coûts qui
n'existe pas comme s'ils étaient dans un
film hong kong et la budget est
d'ailleurs au passage les combats
seraient peut-être un peu plus ça passe
il était pas servi par un cameraman
bourré au pastis qui fera tout pour vous
casser les couilles mais au final le
problème numéro un de ce jeu bah c'est
que les pirouettes le bullet time et
toutes ces conneries
sais rien il faut comprendre que dans
enter the matrix le loch des ennemis
c'est à dire le ciblage est automatique
dès lors il est tellement automatique
que les balles arrivent à partir dans un
sens alors que votre arme pointe dans
une autre direction c'est dire si y'a
pas besoin de bizet mais enfin gagner tu
sais très bien que la matrice fermée
d'altérer la réalité et 2
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un bouge et
aussi vite votre personnage en fait va
automatiquement cibler les ennemis en
fonction de vaguement là où votre caméra
est dirigé et les ennemis dans ce jeu
c'est des gardes des agents des
policiers bref c'est 99% de trucs qui
tire à distance et qui tirent sont très
loin alors au début c'est rigolo on fait
des cabrioles parce que bon c'est matrix
et on est là pour ça après tout mais
passer quelques heures de jeu quand la
difficulté commence à augmenter le
nombre d'ennemis aussi et bien tous les
combats il commence à ressembler à ça
[Musique]
et
au final mais du coup c'est vachement
plus pratique est vachement plus simple
de rester planqué comme une grosse mer
derrière une caisse est butée les gens
de loin surtout que le jeu est assez
généreux avec les éléments subtilement
bien glissé pour tt
quelques faits pourquoi on stocke des
tonneaux explosifs au milieu de la piste
comme ça tu es tout va et quelque chose
derrière
d'ailleurs bon alors vous le voyez un le
jeu de valeur mais je pense que niveau
gameplay n'y a pas vraiment besoin de
détailler les niveaux un parent en fait
le niveau on te donne parfaitement le
ton de ce que va être le jeu dans sa
quasi-intégralité de dire couloir
passe-t-on couloir baston pouvoir baston
avec une variation quand même c'est que
des fois nous aurons des niveaux en
voiture rends-toi où nous ouvrons le feu
numéro deux pour être exemplaire
toujours demandé à l'ennemi de se rendre
après leur tirer dessus
attendez les niveaux en voiture
d'ailleurs c'est car en le truc le plus
naze de ce jeu c'est juste
chiant six niveaux la dure beaucoup trop
longtemps et surtout la bagnole elle est
incontrôlable et c'est du délire c'est
quoi le problème là les roues et son
carré ou quoi
c'est bon j'ai plus rien à rajouter en
fait le jeu il fait des blagues à ma
place mais non ouais bah ça tombe bien
parce que justement c'est le moment de
parler des graphismes puisque dans ce
jeu en gros on alterne donc ça va du
tout juste correct au karément répugnant
avec des passages où tu sens clairement
que les développeurs il n'avait pas
envie de venir bosser ce jour-là money
voyager dans notre toute nouvelle ère
classe
seul siège posé par terre éthiopienne
oui ça existe mais bon heureusement les
développeurs du jeu ont trouvé la
solution pour pallier aux graphismes
passable vous savez les graphismes ils
sont pas moi châssis on peut pas les
voir ce qui nous donne des niveaux
entiers du jeu comme ça
voilà effectivement c'est vrai c'est
comme un match solide cela dit je vais
quand même utiliser les mots de passe si
vous voulez bien pour aller voir la
suite parce que
là j'ai pas trouvé une excuse c'est
juste que j'ai pas envie en fête
foraine log in to drive to save gesse
for any cnao systems command use âge m
commande
invalides commandes news âge elle
commande elle put dire ok elle dira
display l'isof phaidon fowler à
destination usage dire folder or drive
name exemple dire autant de points ordi
rate deux points slash tools à deux
points slash
c'est du dos
c'est du dos quelque part quelqu'un dans
ce monde qui à un moment donné c'est dit
le dos c'est marrant je vais mettre ça
dans un jeu vidéo
ce mec doit avoir une vie horrible le
dos pour les gamins qui regardent c'est
en gros ce qu'il y avait avant windows
ce et des lignes de commande à taper
pour accéder à des dossiers puis des
sous dossiers etc rap c'est chiant c'est
long c'est fastidieux et en général ça
se termine toujours par ces deux mots
magiques commandes invalides aaa ok
alors lisez mes lèvres le dos ça n'est
pas fun et en plus je fais du dos sur
console avec une manette je combine le
pire des deux mondes et je n'arrive même
pas à trouver ou rentrer ce [ __ ] de
mot de passe alors je veux bien rigolé
un moment un peu c'est la matrice ça
rigolo tout ça mais quand dans ce jeu
vidéo je rentre dans un menu mot de
passe un moment j'aimerais bien pouvoir
taper mon mot de passe en moins de 40
minutes bordel de merde
on a un concurrent aux boules de
dragon's faire je vois un félicitations
ailleurs j'ai pas du tout abordé le
scénario alors je vais le faire parce
que ce jeu aurait pu autant s'appelait
under the matrix cinq minutes après néo
parce que la totalité du jeu consiste à
arriver cinq minutes après des eaux et à
faire un résultat on l'a raté encore en
fait pour vous expliquer le jeu est
rempli de scènes cinématiques inédites
avec des acteurs du films qui ont été
tournés en même temps que les films 2 et
3 il sort de profiter des décors mais ma
théorie c'est comme les acteurs allaient
pas s'emmerder à réapprendre des
dialogues justes pour le jeu ben soussan
dion juste refaire pareil voilà donc les
scènes clés du jeu ben c'est les scènes
du film en fait neo va voir le racle
votre personnage va voir l'oracle néo
roule une galoche à perséphone votre
personnage roule une galoche à
perséphone même chose et que ce soit les
plans de caméra ou les dialogues c'est
pareil que le film même la scène ou néo
rate son baiser une première fois avant
de refaire
pareil dans le jeu plus tard neo va voir
le gardien du maître des clefs il se
bastonne avec lui cinq minutes après
dans l'histoire vous arriver et c'est
exactement pareil alors attendez du coup
ça veut dire que dans la même journée
l'asia tu là il a pété la gueule à neo a
ghost et agneaux b il va falloir
apprendre à gérer sa colère monsieur un
moment après savage 10 passes en râlant
non plus je veux dire c'est cool c'est
matrix mais bon c'est vraiment ultra
feignants et au final ma question
d'ailleurs c'est si on refait tout ce
que fait des eaux est proche pas néo
tout simplement c'est justement cette
conclusion qui a guidé le développement
du jeu suivant intitulé the path of neo
ou là pour le coup effectivement on
refait le film mais en jouant des eaux
un jeu qui d'ailleurs suis plutôt bien
le film mais toutes ces scènes clés sans
jamais dérivés
[Musique]
vous noterez que j'ai dit plutôt bien
devant un tribunal ça passe c'est bon je
vous ai trouvé un passage prenez cette
porte et vous arrivez directement code
source bien reçu moule à gaufres j'y
fonce
[Musique]
bonjour grenier je sais qui je suis ces
aides non si non ben si nancy c'est pas
important j'ai choisi cette apparence
parmi d'autres mais je peux prendre
n'importe quelle forme regarde
mais qui êtes vous je fais des
recherches sur ce mec apparemment le jeu
under the matrix a été créé par une
société de nom d'atari mais atari n'est
qu'un autre couverture avance à cette
société porte un autre nom et ce non
c'était et si je prends ce chat par
exemple et que je commence à parler avec
ses taxes a italienne tu ne le connais
je suis le nier à dieu
oui nous sommes partout projetant
d'ailleurs d'envahir la politique très
bientôt pourquoi sujet si les ici parce
que la matrix a poussé à faire un choix
corollaire déguisé sous forme illusoire
de libre arbitre alors que pourtant tu
es esclaves de la causalité inhérentes
ton espèce
c'est la fin de la vidéo ah ok tu es ici
pour achever le cycle entamé il ya dix
ans mettre fin à cette guerre il y à
deux portes celle de gauche mettra fin à
toute cette histoire terminé les jeux
pourris infogrames tu en as fait le tour
cela disparaîtra je disparaîtrai avec
tandis que la porte de droite te mènera
directement
wallet
mais les annotations ça marche plus sur
you tube merde est temps de faire ton
choix mais nous savons tous les deux que
tu veux choisir n'est ce pas ok et si je
repars juste par la porte de chez eux
arrivés se passe quoi non la matrice ne
permet pas de deux
et il est parti il est parti donc donc
ça veut dire que la guerre entre grenier
les jeux pourris le fait que
excusez moi est ce que je pourrais
utiliser vos toilettes en fait en deux
temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]